it's an interesting a couple of weeks
for Konami they put out two games they
put a metal gear solid the phantom pain
ten minute and gamespot com but I pro
evolution soccer 2016 9 out of 10 on
gamespot com yes I'm playing it over the
weekend enjoying it quite a lot slipper
fur FIFA but it's really really good and
but obviously there was a report came
out last week saying that's sort of what
we'd all feared was that Konami were
pulling out of triple-a development
apart from pro evolution which is a sort
of a easy Bank it makes a lot of money
for them in specifically in Japan and
Europe mainland Europe a lot of and
Peter I guess first of all there's since
been another report saying that this
isn't the case but that's from like a
customer service rep or something
somebody put in a support ticket to
konami customer support line saying are
you guys no longer making triple a
console games and the response was of
course we are we're still making
Castlevania Metal Gear like Pez like I
would not put much credence behind this
support ticket response yes one that's
that's no sort of official answer to
that person may not even be at the
company like they could just be a hired
third party who like has like a blanket
slate of things to say and it's just
like yeah so yeah the line they said was
I can promise you that we're definitely
not leaving metal gear behind or
anything like that I know some blogs
were claiming that online this morning
but I'm not really sure where they'd be
getting out of information from like I
don't know two years of looking at Canal
and we're definitely still working on
console games and franchises such as yep
Metal Gear not Medicare solid you're
gonna bring back the MSX games and
Silent Hill Castlevania PES and all the
rest okay so that's four they named and
all the rest let's assume that's three
another that's silent scope and
Bomberman act 0 and dance dance
revolution and you have going on in
there and you have other Hudson
properties but whatever anyway the point
is is that where the hell are they
making these games yeah because they
have like two different studios now and
they they were working with they had a
third party that their camera the name
right now they're working on the
Castlevania games they've shut down
there no longer doing that David Cox the
guy who was ahead of Castlevania left a
person he was in charge of Silent Hill
and metal gear is
to leave any day now yeah I mean who was
making these games where are they
getting made and why the hell should we
believe that they're being made for
consoles there's no evidence to support
it and if there's not an official
statement like these are the games these
are wearing the word they're being made
these are the consoles like we can only
really logically assume that these are
not happening so there was a quote I
can't remember who exactly was with
somebody tied to konami one of the
executives and earlier this week as well
that was basically them saying oh no
we're going to use these properties but
we're not going to use them in the
traditional way we're going to it mobile
games for them we're going to go in like
in different direction towards where
especially the Japanese market is
focused at the moment yeah I mean he
basically said this is our main platform
now then you said if it makes sense down
the road we'll continue making years for
consoles but that doesn't mean anything
it's not like incredibly roaring like
because can I have its it would be one
thing if they stopped making games but
the idea that they're going to be sort
of almost like Disney not releasing DVDs
like they've got this massive chest of
ips that people love but they're going
to be presumably releasing mobile games
maybe pachinko machines about them but
not actual real console games yeah cuz
just last year I remember thinking wow
konami's got a bunch a lot of the good
stuff no they just you know PT had come
out and then they said oh this is
actually gonna be silent Hills and then
you're really excited about that and
then you know they're bringing on
Guillermo Guillermo del Toro and they're
gonna have a norman reedus if that
matters you too much but every time I
kept thinking myself is gonna be awesome
like the Phantom Pain's coming out next
year ground zeroes was great it would
just turned out that's not gonna happen
you know there was a silent Hills
controversy and then all the Kojima
stuff started happening you kind of
realize a lot of these were just maybe
not initially false promises but they
developed into that and then it kind of
just became I feel like they were just
kind of in a kind of sending way saying
yeah we're still having all this coming
out but I just didn't see any evidence
to support that which sucks isn't that
weird because it is kind of a hard swing
Peter when you think about what Mike
resetting last year like there was a lot
of stuff happened or when new
franchisees being announced seems kind
of like a in six months they decided oh
no actually we're going to completely
pull out of console development entirely
well they have completely shifted the
the people at the head at the head of
the company and that sort of came you
know like I love metal gear solid 5 I
respect a lot of boat today Okajima does
i think the sentiment online
is probably accurate when people say
that he you know spent so much time and
money making this game that he probably
doomed the chance for Konami to make
console games in the future you know
specifically when you're trying to
compete with something like this like
how are they going to match this game
yeah like what game can they release
that will stand up to this this game had
astronomical budget like huge ideas is
in development five or six years which
is not unusual these days the sequel to
a long-standing beloved franchise right
so it had that packed into it and so
when you look at mobile development
right they can spend 30 just
hypothetically three months making a
game it catches on in Japan because that
is where the biggest fan base is people
are used to spending money on micro
transactions they're gonna make money
hand over fist why would they want to
support a team that is so large that the
project that's so ambitious that it
could fall apart so you know I think it
makes sense for Konami to do this and
while I will miss the presence of these
series like on shelves and hearing news
online and stuff I don't think ademas
going to stop making games so if you're
a fan of his work you're going to be
able to look forward to stuff I how
could you how can you not keep going but
also I think people need to wake up and
stop demanding that we get another metal
gear or another castlevania I think it's
it's up to creative people that if they
want to support these franchises or at
least the ideas and themes they
represent to take the source material
use it as inspiration build something
new from it and move on like we can't
keep living in the past I mean I'd love
all games I love old series like they're
really important to me but the same time
we need new things and just because they
don't carry the same title doesn't mean
a new game can you know reflect the
things that are wonderful about games
like this from Konami yeah look at what
you guys doing with blood stain it's
very much gonna be a spiritual
predecessor to Castlevania for all
intensive purposes it sounds like it's a
castlevania game without the name
absolutely my number I'm same thing with
it got ya although the quality of that
will eat if uno de funes Aria yeah yeah
so it's just it's it's interesting to
see you know you go went to kicks are
you know like not assuming anything with
kojima but what's to stop him from doing
the same thing yeah i mean and i don't
necessarily want those creators to do
what they have always done I actually I
kind of glad to get that game from you
go now but I'd be interested to see what
he does next and the same with you know
funa like I think rapport is a really
good example of him I mean it's still
taking the
mechanic of you know augmentations you
know like opening up new doors and
abilities and that's great but it's
still a very new universe and it's a new
style of gameplay I want to see Hideo
could you ever do something different
that was I think the promise of silent
Hills was that it was it a totally like
turn turn of direction for him and
that's wonderful so I'd like to see new
talent tackle new series mercury steam
is the name of the company they did
really well by Castlevania I think it
wasn't the old games we loved but it was
a really interesting take that
emphasized things about those games that
had been utilized before like the world
the music like these things were
presented so well you could say the same
thing about revengeance as well
absolutely i love your vengeance and
people you know get upset because oh
well it's not real metal gear game it's
like okay but it's still a wonderful
game like you're looking at it through a
lens that isn't necessarily you know the
same for everybody it's very subjective
so I would like to see these talents do
new things and maybe creators spin-off
stuff that we've loved from the best at
last question on this and I remember a
couple years ago when the success of
mobile games was really kicking off like
Angry Birds is making money hand over
fist before a lot of free-to-play stuff
came into the market and but a lot of
gamers especially online especially on
like message boards and so talking about
how old mobile games are going to be the
death knell for consoles or like this is
a dangerous thing or like being
aggressive towards mobile gaming what
we're having here though is we have a
company like Kaname who is like it an
old name within video games who is
essentially leaving console directions
because of the carrot on the stick that
mobile games is is that something we
should be worried about looking forward
well I think it's going to be there's
going to be a law like we're going to
hit a valley where we see the big name
companies not investing as much in
console games but there's a demand for
big console games that's not necessarily
going away United States and in Europe
and Japan things are changing but and a
lot of the Western gaming markets that's
still up and it's on the rise so I think
even if it's not Konami we're going to
see other companies do it but we still
have plenty of old companies making
great games there's a lot of them happen
to be Japanese at least that come to
mind like Capcom and Square Enix those
guys are still doing some really
pressive work in some areas so I think
console gaming will be fine mobile
gaming will have an impact on it but
it's not going to be I don't think a
death knell for console gaming or PC
gaming or hope not thanks very much
gentlemen for coming on talking about
that
let us know what you think about the sad
demise of Kaname at least in the console
space how you sad will you be happy for
academia to do something new let us know
in the comments below